joy Mangano built a multi-billion dollar
inspired by creating products to solve
everyday problems nearly 30 years ago
the single mother of three invented the
miracle mop she spent about two years
traveling to stores to demonstrate how
it works her big break came when she
pitched it on television for QVC she
sold 18,000 mops in 20 minutes her story
inspired the movie joy Jennifer Lawrence
played the title character she won a
Golden Globe and an Academy Awards
nominations I think nor it's good to be
joy mangano has more than 100 patents
and trademarks for her invention so far
she has sold almost a billion huggable
hangers but you got some of those in
your closet more than six and a half
million of my little steamers and
millions of those miracle mops Mangano's
new book is called inventing joy dare to
build a brave and creative life she
shares her journey to becoming one of
the most accomplished female inventors
and gives advice to find success in
working in life - it's published by
Simon & Schuster which by the way is a
division of CBS we welcome you joy back
to the table it's really good - I'm with
the trio that you're here thank you
thank you I love how you start your book
because even as an early age here you
are 910 years old your little dog Duke
falls in the ice pond and you rescue him
and you come up with a way to put little
booties on it that's right that's right
my point in that story or your story I
think is that even at an early age you
were trying to figure out how to fix
things because you see a product and
solution and everything I look at the
world through product and I didn't know
it at the time right and I did I
continued on through life I was blowing
up toasters I was creating seven story
tree houses and I didn't know my passion
was inventing until I was an adult so
the book goes through this entire
incredible journey it has been talked
about as high-octane optimism and I
think we could all use that in life
today right and it is thrilling it is
sexy it is heartbreaking it is
heartwarming it is comedic the sexy part
is really true
you know what sexy is it your ex-husband
works with you well I yeah okay
family members I do I do I believe in
circling back and you know maybe not the
best marriage but their attributes a
father and a great salesman and a great
friend right so I think that I wanted
this book to be something when somebody
closed it and it's certainly a
page-turner where they would walk away
having a better life having a more
joyful life I can't wait to go to bed
just so I can wake up in the morning not
as early as you guys but think abut
exactly and start all over because I'm
living my passion and everybody should
discover that and they will these are
the tools to give anybody that ability
to what's the most important tool well I
think the most important tool is to know
that you can shift your skis I say and
that is the ability to discover yourself
and go in a path that may not be the
path you're on it's never too late and
it's never too early to take that path
so here I was inventing a mop
right and I thought I want to sell it in
stores across America but I find myself
on a stage in front of a hundred million
homes talking about this mop and I never
expected to be there but that was the
path that took that that took me right
what do you think is the linchpin
between creativity and execution because
I know a lot of moms there we talk about
great ideas that they would want to
invent yep but the execution is harder
exactly how many times even in fact so
this is for everybody everybody has a
door into this book and so many people
as I hear it every day a hundred times a
week I have a great idea so it's the
execution behind that you must you must
know that you don't have to be an expert
in something to get started and
sometimes the simplest things truly
change lives it doesn't have to be
rocket ships so and I was a mom a single
mom with three little children and I
literally shifted my whole life and said
I am going to try this if you don't try
you absolutely have a hundred percent of
getting nowhere I think your best advice
is don't be afraid of hearing no oh you
know it's just the start of a
negotiation right no is the beginning
that I heard no you can't sell a
self-wringing mop no you can't sell
velvety hangers
I I hear more nose today right when you
have something that you want to do we
all do and it's a matter of how do I
shift that into something else how do i
turn the no into a yes right and
therefore that's a start of something
else you rethink it and be realistic but
it will take you to some beautiful
places and I promise
whether you are young whether you're old
if certainly if you're I'm a female so
young women don't have to do it all this
book is all the tools and the principles
that have led me to success on all
levels we just say Joy's doing okay she
has a 40,000 square foot house and
people who love her and care about her
that's a empathy is crucial to success
Jennifer large plays are on them and a
very dear friend of mine joy Mangano is
doing all right and still on the air too
still in the air selling stuff there you
go inventing joy is on sale right now
wherever you like to buy your books